Heads and it's a star wars
one at Disneyland, Dude.
It's fucking why you go across,
you're walking across you,
you can really get a workout with that.
I'm not joking. You get exhausted. Yeah.
And you know, you, you keep
going and fight tougher and
tougher opponents, right?
Well, yeah, that's it. And
that's the quite, you know,
so like talk about haptic suits,
like where eventually you know you're
going to wear things. I didn't see the,
I read the book but I didn't see the,
uh, what was it? The movie that ready,
set ready player one.
I didn't see it either.
They didn't see you
have you read the book?
The book's really good because
the book is like full immersion.
Like the whole book is about
like when virtual reality is it.
And so everybody has the suits that, you
know, and you're kind of in this ball,
you play the game in a boiler, you can run
and you know, um, but in some sense, yes,
we're just starting out along these lines,
but they have these places you can go,
they have a warehouse set
up and you go inside of it.
And I went through one with my kids.
And it's a star wars one at Disneyland,
Dude.
It's fucking why you go across,
you're walking across this platform,
like they have all these different places
where you actually walk through and as
you're walking through, you look to the
left and to the right and there's fire,
but you feel the heat from the fire.
It's fucking crazy.
Like heater set up so that it blows up
and storm troopers starts shooting at you.
This is it right here. What is it
called? The void. The void. Yeah.
And you do this.
I'm telling you man,
this is better than any of the rides
at Disneyland and it's just outside of
Disneyland and downtown Disney.
So you don't have to pay to get into
Disney and you get it. But it costs,
I think it's $35 for a half an hour.
It's not cheap, but it's not too bad.
It's not too bad. Like it's fucking
awesome. I mean it is awesome.
And so the question is what happens
with all of this, right? Future, right?
Cause you have virtual reality.
We're just on the cusp of it. Right.
We're just beginning to like start
playing around with these technologies
because people have been saying it
for years and it kind of sucked.
It was sort of clunky. We're,
we used to play Pong, right?
That's what I started with. How old are
you? 55 yeah, I'm 50 so I remember Pong.
We were excited.
I can't believe I'm controlling the TV,
making the thing move on the TV
or asteroids slew the, Oh yeah.
Was a star wars game,
I think it was called asteroids.
But you flew through the trenches
wire frame, but it was amazing.
I dropped a lot of quarters.
Sure.
So go from that to what you were showing
us here with these crazy new space
games. And then imagine what these
mean. The star wars thing today,
the void is really cool, but you know
that it's not real, but it's cool.
Right. But you know it's not real. Well,
you're not going to be able to tell.
It's not real in 20 years. Yeah. Right.
And how much time are you willing to
spend it, by the way, when you do that?
Oh really pressure you and you feel
it when you get getting shot. Wow.
You feel like, I never,
you know, it's funny,
even with the controller on my
crappy ps four who, um, yeah,
but it vibrates when you,
you know, sort of give you,
it's amazing how much the brain sort of
picks up on these signals when you're
using the HTC vive and you draw an Arrow
back. When it gets to the nocking point,
you feel it, like you release,
there's a feeling in your hand and you're
seeing the arrow. It's really cool.
Yeah. So what happens when, and you're
right, I can be sorta like, you know,
you're like, that's terrible. People
shouldn't be going out in nature,
which I think they should be. They should,
you know, now, but, you know, I always,
I'm always aware whenever I'm sort of
like, oh shit, this is gonna be terrible.
I always remember the whole, you can
see it in like, I think at some point,
Socrates, you know, 2005 years,
500 years ago, it was like,
Ooh, kids to do the role.
Bunch of old. Right. Um, so you know, who
knows what we'll do with it and you know,
hopefully, you know, maybe it'll help,
you know, maybe, I don't know. You know,
I mean I think there is, I don't
want to be like, oh that's terrible,
but there clearly are is going to be
dangerous with just a different game.
Jamie this is a new one. Oh boy. Fuck I,
I'm going to be fucked shooting at
these yet. Just the hands. Yeah.
And so your,
you have two little hand controllers and
one of them would be the Arrow and the
other one would be the bow and you wear
them and that's the haptic part and
it'll controllers on them.
Well you feel the Arrow vibrating against
the riser of the row as you draw it
back to.
It's really cool.
Well it's funny cause you know
we talked about like you know,
for the the game that we built,
which was awesome.
It was really a lot of fun to actually go
through the process of like how do you,
how do you script it? How do you
teach people, you know, like,
cause that whole thing that when we get
in a good way, when you're a good game,
right?
You know,
the first couple hours of a game and
you're just learning the basic stuffs and
you get excited, you're like, oh this
is, this is a cool world to be in. Um,
but I'd be interested to
think like sort of, you know,
at some point did tried VR for the
same thing because what can you,
once you can tap, have people be tactile
and then have to sort of in their head,
what else can you do to short of show
them, teach them things you know,
like glaciers or you know,
I mean sure.
Well that's another thing in Disneyland
they have a thing called soaring over
the world that you sit in a chair and you,
you get raised up and there's a giant
like imax style screen and it flies you
over these environments.
It's incredible.
It's so beautiful and different smells
are in the air and the different places
that you go to.
Like when you go over the elephant,
the elephant's you smell
grass and hay. And, um,
I think that it's just a matter of time,
like as we were talking about before
where biological entities might not be
necessary for space travel.
You might be able to send a robot,
put on a suit and be able to experience
these worlds, right? Like in real time.
Well, um, so you know, you
know, the simulation argument,
the philosophy argued about the,
you know,
and so that's a really interesting idea.
Should we just run through it for people
who don't know, so I forgot who it was,
Nick Bostrom and now maybe not Brandon
Carter. You know, there's this, uh,
this guy philosopher came with
this brilliant argument for like,
why we're probably a simulant,
we're probably somebody else's simulation,
self aware of simulation. And the idea
is like, look, if you get one, you know,
we've been talking about
like civilizations, when they
get a million years ahead,
what can they do that they're so powerful,
they can build computers
that can simulate reality,
like fully simulate reality where like,
you know, just like in the matrix,
you have programs that are
self aware and so, you know,
once they get to that and they start
running simulations of the world, right?
It's cheaper to run.
It's cheap to run simulations.
So they just run trillions of them,
right?
So the idea is that from that argument
there's more simulated realities then
there is the one real reality.
So odds are right, you know,
if there's a trillion simulated
realities and one real reality,
you're probably in a simulated
reality. So are we a, you know,
everything like right now you, and
I think this is real, you know,
but what we are is an incredibly detailed
and we are self aware programs in
silicon matrix of, you know, uh,
so that argument is brilliant.
I mean, you know, I mean just from the,
just from the point of view
of like numbers, um, yeah,
there's lots of reasons to say that's
not possible, but, but it's, you know,
raises this issue of like,
yeah, what is simulation?
But if you are in a simulation,
the whole matrix thing,
if you are in a simulation that was
that real, how would you know? Yeah,
how could you know there are gay,
we're going to be,
if you allow technology to continue,
right?
If we keep moving forward
at an exponential pace,
there's gonna come a point in
time what we have something that's
indistinguishable from reality,
right?
So how do we know that we're not
already in it? Once we're in it,
will we create another reality?
Will we continue to create simulations
inside of simulations like fractals,
fractals exist nature, they exist
everywhere in the universe. And there's,
there's also the argument that the
atomic structure itself might really be a
universe. Right? Right. Yeah.
That's super stoner talk. But you
know, it's really, I mean, what,
that's why I love science fiction, you
know, the explorations of these ideas,
you know, I mean they're way out there
and there, but know exercises, exercises.
And there's a way in which again,
when you think 1,000,002 million years
in the future, this is why might one of,
you know, I hate the loop this back
to climate change, but just like God,
if we could just make it through,
who the fuck knows what we're going to be.
Right. I mean there's, there's the whole
universe. One thing I did like about, um,
interstellar, what's the idea
that like our future selves,
which have now become integrated,
the very fabric of reality, you know,
that's how far you've evolved.
You become the laws of
physics that they're kind of
opening up the wormhole for
us. And so, you know,
a million years is so long and that know
who knows what we can become and it's
just like, you know, don't hold
us back. I mean, I'm, you know,
I'm not a fan of the
people that deny science,
but one thing I am a fan
of is watching them do it.
Like watching monkeys
throw shit at the zoo.
It's just something weird about watching
people argue like really obvious,
right wing talking points and,
and, and most of them, by the way,
have no financial interest in
climate change one way or the other.
They're not,
they're not the wealthy elite.
There are these Weirdos that are like
the empire familiars like they want to be
recognized as like an eight,
an ally of the elite.
They think somehow knew that
that was going to get to,
and it's really what it is, right? Yeah.